karl lauterbach der sendet 24 stunden
überall seit zwei jahren in der korona
krise er spricht erklärt das ist gut
aber zu oft sagt er heute das und morgen
dann leider was anderes jetzt sorgt
dieser fernseh auftritt von karl
lauterbach bei markus lanz für heftige
kritik wegen der lauterbachs behauptung
auch die ergebnisse von corona
schnelltests würden in die offizielle
statistik einfließen
also wenn er an das gesundheitsamt
gemeldet wird zählt natürlich auch der
anti gen test
ja also das müssen wir unter die lupe
nehmen lauterbach sagte an dem ganz
kurzen ausschnitt das auch schnell
testergebnisse in die offizielle corona
statistik einfließen was stimmt was
nicht bildpolitik chef jan schäfer beim
rk ii gestern nachgefragt besser gesagt
der kollege philipp hat gestern
nachgefragten hat die antwort vom rk ii
bekommen nein die aussage von karl
lauterbach ist falsch also wirklich nur
pcr tests fließen ein in die statistik
also offenbar hat er sich geirrt aber
wie kann man dann überhaupt darauf die
kammer auf den gedanken dass auch die
schnelltests mit einfließen wir hören
aus der regierung dass es überlegungen
gibt weil wir bei pcr tests ja probleme
sehen was die verteilung angeht dass man
künftig möglicherweise auch diese
schnelltests mit einbeziehen möchte das
wird aber gerade noch diskutiert dazu
gibt es noch gar keinen festen stand
möglicherweise hat karl lauterbach das
einfach schon vor ausgenommen einmal
mehr und hat so programmiert als wenn es
diese diesen sind faktisch schon geben
würde tut es aber an dass noch einmal
reinschauen in den kurzen ausschnitt von
marx und markus lanz
eine busse impfung für alle wäre jetzt
auf keinen fall sinnvoll wir haben zum
einen kann einen medizinischen grund den
booster für alle jetzt anzubieten weil
die impfung für die unter 65 70 jährige
noch wirksam ist sehr gut wirksam ist
zwar hatten wir auch voraus mir das ist
der nase ton über den wir reden
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer dass
lauterbach hin und her denn auch das hat
karl lauterbach in dieser krise gesagt
dass boostern wird hier nicht für jeden
nötig seien und wenig später hat er das
gesagt
es ist klar seit ein paar monaten dass
wir halt jeden erwachsenen ostern ist
seit ein paar monaten ein paar monaten
ist das klar das ist klar und das haben
also spezialisten auch also relativ früh
zu sagen und dann ist muss dahinter zu
hören ist er dann ist argument dann ist
also zunächst einmal ausgerechnet worden
können wir das dann schaffen durch die
niedergelassenen kollegen allein lauter
jahr lautern ein mal so mal so heute so
morgen so ist das ganz normal in dieser
corona krise in der ja man immer von
neuen herausforderungen steht oder ist
das auch ein bisschen ein lauterbach
phänomen dass ein lauterbach phänomen
und ist es zum einen lauter jahr lauter
nein aber es auch lauter hin lauter her
denn das was wir gerade gesehen haben
ist natürlich
maximal auch sozusagen wasser auf die
mühlen derjenigen die ohnehin mit der
politik unzufrieden sind wir sehen es
bei karl lauterbach immer wieder dass er
sich korrigieren muss er ist auch so
etwas wie ein nicht nur
gesundheitsminister sondern auch horror
prognosen minister wir haben es vor
weihnachten gesehen wir haben letztes
jahr vor ostern gesehen dass er
wirkliche horror prognosen was
beispielsweise die zahl der infizierten
angeht oder die belegung von
intensivbetten an die wand malt am ende
stellen wir fest deutlich unter der
latte durch zum glück muss man sagen
aber diese horror prognosen sind nie in
kraft getreten oder sind überhaupt die
haben sich nie bewahrheitet und von
daher muss man sagen das was er dort
macht dieses hin und her auf der einen
seite einmal boostern er nicht und dann
doch auf jeden fall wieder oder auch die
anderen prognosen mit denen er auch
immer wieder die öffentlichkeit schockt
die tragen nicht dazu bei dass die
glaubwürdigkeit in die politik steigt
der pflicht das ist gerade das thema das
ganz ganz viele menschen hier in
deutschland wirklich auf wright und da
tut sich ja auch die bundesregierung
sehr sehr schwer einmal hü einmal hott
man weiß nicht genau wie man das
umsetzen kann fakt ist sie ist nicht da
in österreich gingen sie gestern durch
und hier fragen sich viele menschen nach
was passiert jetzt überhaupt damit auch
dazu gibt es ein statement von karl
lauterbach das eventuell mehr fragen als
antworten geben könnte ich glaube dass
also ärzte jeden impfen sollten
denjenigen der geimpft werden will weil
er im pflicht nachkommt oder denjenigen
der sich impfen lässt ganz freiwillig es
wird ja niemand gegen seinen willen
geimpft selbst impfpflicht führte dazu
dass man sich zum schluss freiwillig
impfen lässt die impfpflicht die dazu
führt dass man sich am ende freiwillig
impfen lassen das klingt ein bisschen
wie ein hohn also man könnte fast sagen
deutsch karl lauterbach karl lauterbach
deutschmann musste das vielleicht
übersetzen mein eindruck ist was er
damit sagen wollte dass wenn diese
impfpflicht kommt dass das den druck
erhöht sich impfen zu lassen das ist ja
auch der sinn aber kern ist natürlich
wir haben es beim thema impfpflicht mit
ganz ganz vielen nebelgranaten zu tun
auch vom
bundesgesundheitsminister selbst aber
auch der bundeskanzler und viele andere
ministerpräsidenten die seit wochen seit
monaten dafür trommeln sind uns
eigentlich bisher die erklärung schuldig
geblieben wie genau diese impfpflicht
umgesetzt werden soll karl lauterbach
trägt jetzt mit diesem statement einmal
mehr zur verunsicherung bei also es ist
ein tollhaus was wir sehen in sachen
impfpflicht niemand weiß wie es
umgesetzt werden soll und offenbar
widerspricht sich der minister in
gewisser weise auch selbst impfpflicht
bedeutet ja dass sich jeder zwangsweise
impfen müsste und er referierte auf eine
aussage des kassen- ärztepräsidenten
gassen der gesagt hat die ärzte wollen
in ihren praxen da nicht zwangsweise
impfen also tollhaus impfpflicht wir
hoffen dass wir nächste woche ein
bisschen mehr klarheit haben aber klar
ist die regierung ist in der pflicht und
es ist erstaunlich dass bisher noch
niemand sagen kann wie dieser weg zu
impfpflicht eigentlich aussehen soll wie
erklärst du dir ja das ist so viel
lauterbach jan ein hin und her gibt dass
es so viel verwirrung letztendlich auch
stiften kann bei ganz vielen menschen
etwas er selbst auf meinem interview
verraten wie sehr er sich mit studien
beschäftigt dass sie bis tief in die
nacht herein ließ um jede studie die
auch aus den usa frisch kommt doch
irgendwie in sein wissen auf zu fassen
wie erklärst du dir dann dass es auf so
zickzack
ich glaube was wir in der pandemie sehen
ist natürlich dass gewisse dinge die man
vorausgesagt hat für ein oder zwei
monate sich manchmal auch anders
entwickeln und an das ergeben und
insofern ist es sicherlich auch in
ordnung dass sich der ein oder andere
korrigiert ich glaube es ist bloß
wichtig dass man das dann auch ganz klar
sagt und sagt okay hier habe ich mich
geirrt hier lag ich falsch das sind
dinge die man von karl lauterbach aber
bisher nicht hört und ich glaube das
trägt zur ehrlichkeit da nicht gerade
bei also es wäre gut wenn ein minister
der auch gefühlt schon ganz ganz lange
ja bundesgesundheitsminister ist am ende
auch mal sagt hier lag ich falsch
korrektur so muss es richtig sagt das
ist interessant weil gerade der
expertenrat der bundesregierung das ja
immer jetzt sind seine papiere schreibt
dass man klar kommunizieren möchte mit
uns mit allen bürgern und bürgerinnen in
deutschland in dieser so schwierigen
corona krise mit politik schlecht wie
jan schäfer über den lauterbach zickzack
den lauter hin und her wie er sagt
vielen dank und wir schaffen klarheit in
sachen corona zahlen schauen rau 4 auf
unseren großen monitor mit den aktuellen
infektionszahlen und von dieser kurve
hier gibt es aktuell noch keine gute
nachrichten die steigt und steigt wir
testen und testen und testen und omikron
verbreitet sich weiter rasant in
deutschland das heißt wir haben aktuell
neue höchstwerte wieder bei den
infektionszahlen über 140.000 diese zahl
darauf können wir uns jetzt schon
einstellen die wird in den nächsten
tagen und wochen weiter erst mal steigen
bevor und das ist dann wiederum die ganz
gute nachricht erwartet wird dass sie
dann rasant wieder abreißt das haben
andere länder ja vorgemacht zunächst
südafrika mittlerweile auch
großbritannien und andere länder die uns
eben voraus sind aber wir haben eine
ganz gute nachricht hier auf dieser
karte auch die zahl der todesfälle immer
noch natürlich zu hoch aber sie singt
seit einigen tagen werden jetzt 170
todesfälle in deutschland mit corona in
den vergangenen 24 stunden also diese
kurve sinkt und im vergleich dieser
beiden kurven sehen sie jetzt schon die
infektionszahlen breiten sich aus die
todesfälle sinken aktuell das heißt hier
steckt schon drin das omikron offenbar
eben weniger tödlich weniger gefährlich
für uns ist wir schauen auf die hotspots
aktuell in deutschland
wir sehen eine rote karte die uns so
aktuell aber nicht mehr allzu sehr
schrecken mag wir sehen neuerdings eben
hotspots hier auch im norden in
brandenburg in mecklenburg vorpommern in
hamburg und schleswig holstein gibt
biete die bis vor zwei wochen noch
komplett grün waren aber was sind dann
die auswirkungen in den krankenhäusern
darauf kommt es an und diese karte ist
nicht rot aktuell sie kennen diese
schwellenwerte von der hospitalisierung
since it ends 36 und 99 der warnwert
sozusagen und den erreichen wir aktuell
in deutschland nirgendwo außer in bremen
etwas brisanter die lage auch hier jetzt
ausgerechnet im norden in schleswig
holstein wo es so lange entspannt war in
bundesländern in dem die impfquoten
interessanterweise sehr hoch sind in
bremen ist die impfquote die höchste da
wir aber gleichzeitig die höchste
belastung in den krankenhäusern und dann
zum vergleich ausgerechnet hier in
sachsen wo die impfquote geringer ist
haben wir aktuell die niedrigsten
instanzen und die niedrigste
hospitalisierung incidents dass also die
wahrheit über die krankenhaus belegung
aktuell in dieser krise keine entspannte
situation aber bei weitem keine so
dramatische lage wie etwa zwei wochen
vor weihnachten patricia